So You've probably heard about climate change
just about everywhere.
But what exactly is climate change and global
warming?
On a very basic level, it's the world heating
up.
Climate change is a very complex beast, with
hundreds of factors, but let's talk about
the fundamental cause at the root at it all,
Carbon Dixoide, or CO2.
Carbon Dioxide is a naturally occurring gas,
it's inside us and everywhere around us, so
why is everyone so up in arms about it?
Well for hundreds of thousands of years the
CO2 levels in the atmosphere have been relatively
stable, hovering around 250 parts per million
(PPM).
But the industrial revolution in the past
few hundred years and the drastic increase
of fossil fuels being burnt has caused the
CO2 levels to shoot up to around 390 parts
per million (PPM).
This is bad because Carbon Dioxide behaves
like a greenhouse, letting heat from the sun
into the earth's atmosphere very easily, but
making it very hard for it to escape.
Whilst CO2 is the biggest contributor to the
greenhouse effect, other gases come into play
as well.
Methane, Nitrous Oxide and Chlorofluorocarbon
or "CFC", all of which have an effect on climate
change.
The biggest human cause of climate change
is the burning of fossil fuels to generate
energy, the same energy you use every time
you switch a light on.
65% of carbon emissions come from the burning
of fuels.
21% of carbon emissions come from transport,
7% comes from methane emissions from agricultural
livestock, going about their business.
And the rest comes from various other sources.
But here's the kicker, humans only contribute
around 0.28% of global greenhouse gases, the
rest comes from natural sources, such as volcanos
and the oceans.
Of course they don't tell you that on the
news, because it's much less terrifying and
nobody would care about climate change.
But if human contributions are so small why
should we care?
Well the truth is 0.28% is terrifying, and
you have good reason to be worried.
Since the formation of the earth greenhouse
gases have been in a fine balance, massive
amounts of gases, mostly methane, have been
constantly released from volcanic eruptions
for over 4.54 billion years, but most of these
harmful gases have been absorbed back into
the oceans, stopping any greenhouse effects
from kicking in and taking over.
But in the short time humans have been emitting
greenhouse gases we have pushed the levels
over the edge, it's like a straw braking the
camel's back.
That small 0.28% of greenhouse gases is enough
to send the CO2 levels into harmful amounts
resulting in exponentially increasing CO2
levels.
Humans are producing more carbon than the
oceans can handle.
The oceans can only absorb so much carbon,
so the remainder is sent into the atmosphere,
and when that happens, you're gonna have a
bad time.
All these effects are compounded by the rapid
deforestation of the earth's rain forests.
Since trees directly reverse the effects of
global warming, by taking in carbon dioxide
and releasing oxygen, through a process called
photosynthesis.
The more trees we cut down, the less CO2 is
removed from the atmosphere and this results
in a vicious cycle and rapidly increasing
CO2 levels.